[Musik]
führen sie tagebuch und wenn ja was
würden wir wohl was sie erfahren wenn
wir darin lesen könnten
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
religion mein heutiger gast befasst sich
nicht mit dem tagebuch eines einzelnen
menschen sondern mit dem der ganzen
menschheit herzlich willkommen kann
streiten sich selbst tagebuch neuen habe
ich nie gemacht
nur wissenschaftlich also nicht nicht so
ein persönliches tagebuch somit ein
schlösschen drauf was denken sie warum
schreiben menschen tagebüchern genau das
haben wir uns das auch überlegt aus
diese titel von unserem buch erwähnt
wurde
man schreibt ja tagebuch wenn man sich
mit etwas auseinander setzen muss wenn
man verwirrt ist wenn man sich wundert
was los ist und so haben wir die
geschichte der biblischen autoren
gedeutet dass man sagt wir haben alle
diese probleme
wir wissen nicht wo die herkommen damals
wussten sie vielleicht nicht dass sie
neu waren sie haben sich nur gewundert
was passiert uns alles hier und es passt
nicht zu unserem was wir dann
menschliche natur nennen unsere ersten
natur unsere referenzen die wir
eigentlich so haben und dann versucht
man sich die zu bewältigen sagt man man
schreibt auf was so los ist und in einem
dialog mit sich selbst versucht man dann
lösungen so allmählich zu formulieren
und so kann man so kann man die bibel
ist aus einer reihe von lösungen ein
erklärungsmodell könnte man sagen und
elend den man dem mann ausgesetzt war
könnte man sagen wir werden noch tiefer
darauf eingehen was ihr
auseinandersetzung der bibel betrifft
aber ursprünglich kommt aus einem ganz
anderen gebiet die haben über viele
jahre die orang utans er vor allem
verhalten erforscht sozusagen die
forschung am lebenden objekt und nun
plötzlich die forschung an einem toten
objekt an einem alten buch an der bibel
was ist das für ein evolutionärer
schritt den sie da gemacht
das tut weh
aber es ist nicht so weit entfernt wie
man vielleicht denken würde denn wieso
studiert man menschenaffen im
allgemeinen und affen sogar das ist um
menschen besser zu verstehen also ich
bin jetzt anthropologe das bedeutet dass
ich verstehen möchte wo kommen wir her
wie sie sind wir als menschen entstanden
da müssen wir vergleiche machen wir
können auch natürlich mario
paläontologische also fossilien aus
graben das muss man allmählich zusammen
passen wir nehmen noch lebenden menschen
affenarten die natürlich nicht genau wie
unseren vorfahren waren aber sehr viel
gemeinsames hatten und so können wir
rekonstruieren was in der menschwerdung
sich geändert hat
und wenn wir das so machen und sehen wir
dann allmählich kristallisiert sich da
eine ziemlich klare geschichte aus von
einem aufrecht gehenden menschen auch
von art in afrika die zum jäger und
sammler geworden ist allmählich
und dann hören wir auf schritt schnitt
bei so ungefähr 10.000 jahre
denn ja da kam die landwirtschaften dann
wurde alles anders
verstehe ich sie richtig sie haben ja
sie kommen ja ursprünglich aus der
zoologie aber ihr interesse galt primär
eigentlich der erkenntnis über das
menschsein hüfte erkenntnis imitieren
man verwendet diese forschung und es
gibt ja es gibt zwei große fragen womit
ich meine grund vorlesung auch immer
anfangen
wieso gibt es das universum und wie ist
es entstanden und wieso gibt es menschen
wo kommen die her sind wir eigentlich
und vielleicht auch noch ostern hingehen
könnte aber das lassen wir dann meistens
seien also das ist eine sehr grosse
frage man versucht einfach alles was
dabei helfen könnte einzubeziehen um
diese rekonstruktion es ist ein mann
erzählt eine geschichte wider so so
genau wie möglich wieder um diese
rekonstruktion so gut wie möglich zu
machen und das haben sie sich dann an
die bibel gewagt sie nennen das selber
im buch ein etwas größenwahnsinniges
unterfangen
wir müssen aber auch erwähnen sie haben
dieses buch nicht alleine geschrieben
nämlich zusammen mit keimen
in einem wissenschaftsjournalisten und
historiker warum mit einem historiker
nicht an geologen hätte auch sein können
es hat sich einfach aus zufällig so
ergeben dass er hat mich mal wegen einem
interview gesprochen und da haben wir
noch ein bisschen weiter geplaudert und
ich hatte mal erst gesagt hast das dass
die vertreibung aus dem paradies das ist
doch ganz eindeutig sieht man da die
entstehung der landwirtschaft und an
deren folgen
und dann hat er gehorcht und gesagt dass
du entspannend es gibt ein zwei leute
haben wir jetzt entdeckt die das auch
mal erwähnt haben aber nicht wirklich
thematisiert und und grundsätzlich so
versucht systematisch durchzugehen
ob das eine these ist die sich die sich
aufrecht erhalten lässt und wir sind
jetzt überzeugt dass zumindest im
grundriss diese sachen schon stimmen
dass man also dass das gen ist ist
eigentlich wie sie benennen ist
katastrophen katalog könnte man sagen wo
alles was alles schief gegangen ist und
dann kommen die vier weitere bücher von
mose und wo eigentlich die lösungen
formuliert werden um diese katastrophe
zu bewältigen
wir werden diese beete vielleicht uns
dir der noch etwas genauer annähern
gleich was mich zunächst noch
interessiert sie haben keinen explizit
religiösen zugang gesucht und dahin
strickt naturwissenschaften um zugang
gesucht und sie erwähnen auch eingangs
des buches ihre agnostische haltung
etwas kritisch nachgefragt oder eine
eine kritische konfrontation mir scheint
es oft dass wissenschaftler den in
anspruch nehmen durch ihren
agnostizismus sozusagen die
unvoreingenommenheit zu demonstrieren
die objektivität zu demonstrieren aber
sie selbst wurden wahrscheinlich als
jemand der in westeuropa aufgewachsen
ist und sozialisiert wurde auch in einem
gewissen sinn will durch christlicher
geschichten biblische geschichten so
zahle sich jetzt legen sie diese brille
vollkommen ab
das ist natürlich schwierig aber wie
charles darwin schon gesagt hat wenn man
einen fehler macht dann gibt es viele
die ganz ganz gerne
darauf hinweisen dass man einen fehler
gemacht hat also aus
naturwissenschaftler muss man immer
davon ausgehen dass was man produziert
vorläufiges wissen ist und
modifizierbare wissen und vielleicht
ganz falsch obwohl die evidenz natürlich
letztendlich muss die evidenz also die
balance der videos muss es muss
entscheiden ja also das was aber uns
wirklich erstaunt hat ist dass diese
bislang ist die dritte lesart so wenig
gemacht worden ist denn einerseits lesen
leute natürlich und das ist ja auch die
die absicht heutzutage zumindest das
wort gottes was gar nicht davon werden
und dann ist unser ansatz bisschen fehl
am platz vielleicht sogar vielleicht
blasphemisch okay aber stellen sie sich
mal vor sie würden hindu bücher lesen
oder andere bücher dann können sie das
auch relativ frisch lesern und
unvoreingenommen die zweite lesart die
heutzutage sehr populär ist ist dass man
sagt alles was in der bibel steht ist
quatsch und dann sucht man eigentlich
nur zu zeigen wo unstimmigkeiten da sind
wo es nicht zusammenpasst oder ja hier
sagt man das und da sagt man das
umgekehrte wie zu erwarten das wenn sein
tagebuch ist übrigens und also dass die
die lesen die bibel nicht so wie wir das
lesen wie genau formulieren sie mal was
heißt das denn jetzt genau die bibel
anthropologisch zu lesen um zu schauen
etwas was wie gesagt aus tagebuch womit
haben die leute sich damals
auseinandergesetzt und was wer waren
damals ihre lösungsansätze
das sind konnte kulturelle lösungen ob
es jetzt einen gott gibt oder nicht
lassen wir einfach stehlen das gehen sie
vielleicht zu einem beispiel über diese
sündenfalls geschichte im paradies wie
sie im ersten testament der bibel
erwähnt wird nimmt einen großen platz in
ihren überlegungen im buch einfach
formulieren sie das mal war um was geht
es denn bei ihnen jetzt in der
betrachtung dieser geschichte also alle
motive werden aus dem paradies
vertrieben
und dann steht da dann kommt
noch eine ganze reihe aussagen von gott
so aus als nachschub jetzt musst du in
dein brot mit mühe essen du musst die
frauen werden mit mühe gebärden gebären
du musst dein im acker rumtoben du musst
alles selber machen jetzt das war also
nicht so vorher und es geht es wird
allerhand probleme geben also das hat
man damals die die autoren haben das als
bestrafung gesehen aber was da klar wird
ist die landwirtschaft uns wir müssen
auch also manchmal sieht eigentlich wenn
man es wenn man so zeile für zeile durch
geht sieht man sehr viele beispiele wo
man denkt hey das hat mit landwirtschaft
zu tun also die bibel beschreibt quasi
diesen übergang von einer nomadischen
gesellschaft hin zu einer sesshaft
werden und noch ein noch einen schritt
weiter nicht nur das sesshaft werden das
an sich schon eine wichtige rolle spielt
aber auch dass man seine eigene nahrung
produziert und nicht nur lebt vom was es
irgendwo noch zu finden ist
das ist also das hat so viele
konsequenzen gehabt und das wird auch
immer klarer die die archäologen und und
andy erforschen das natürlich und
eigentlich ist es ist eine perfekte
widerspiegelung was sind das für große
konsequenzen die das gehabt hat ja wo
fangen wir an also ich habe vieles lässt
sich organisieren rund um das konzept
von eigentum jäger sammler haben sehr
wenig private eigentümer die haben wir
vielleicht ein paar werkzeuge und das
war s dann alles wird geteilt
das müssen sie ob sie jetzt das spontan
so gerne wollen oder nicht dass das ist
so ihre kultur
dann sieht man an und plötzlich zum
beispiel wird ein baum wird jemals
eigentum also wenn ich vorbei gehen und
einfach die birne nehme oder die äpfel
dann ist das jetzt falsch
das war nie falsch ist also ihre
anspielung an dieser paradies situation
ja sozusagen als auch dieses dieses
verbot gegenüber adam und eva
und nehmen ja da da könnte man natürlich
ich meine das sind sowieso mehrere
geschichten in der name geflossen
die möglicherweise schon sehr alt sind
wir wollen nicht unterstellen dass da
irgendwie das kollektive gedächtnis so
weit zurückgeht dass man das alles genau
genau irgendwie oder oder halbwegs noch
geahnt hat oder so was
aber es passt schon sehr schön drin bei
anderen sachen ist es klar es ist man
kann so sagen die angeborenen
präferenzen die veranlagten
prädispositionen die man hat die passe
nicht zum neuen leben und dass da gibt
es eine reibung deshalb tagebuch und
genau das hat dazu geführt dass man
versucht ja was haben und hat das aus
strafe erfahren monotheismus kommen wir
vielleicht noch drauf und das hat dazu
geführt dass man gesagt okay welche
lösungen müssen wir jetzt formulieren
also sie sprechen ein buch häufig von
diesen misna krisen nicht zueinander
passenden passe teilen wo sich kein
kohärentes bild genau ergibt und neben
der sündenfall geschichte erwähnen sie
als beispiel auch die geschichte von
kain und abel ob die beiden brüder die
wo der eine den anderen erschlägt nun wo
es auch um eine ungleichheit geht in der
behandlung der eine ist okay bauer und
50 benachteiligt gegenüber dem viel
power wie wie gehen sie an diese
geschichte heran kommen wir zurück zum
großen thema eigentum
jetzt ist man angesiedelt man hat land
jetzt hat man kinder
man muss vererben nein vielleicht einen
schritt vorher man hat land wenn es wenn
es produktiv ist sind da viele leute das
gerne übernehmen möchten was bedeutet
dass man muss verteidigen
wir sind einer menschenaffenart das
bedeutet die menschen also unsere männer
übernehmen diese rolle
sie brauchen aber allianzpartner und der
sind das die verwandt mit
nichtverwandten ist es immer ein
bisschen heikel und man nimmt seinen
verwandten das bedeutet väter sein onkel
so entsteht das patriarchen
die patrizia ali t also man möchte dass
seine kinder das land erben
aber wenn denn wenn man es gleich
verteilt dann ist es sehr schnell vorbei
es sei denn man expandiert sehr schnell
und es können nicht alles geht auch
nicht immer gut also man muss regeln
machen neue regel wer kriegt jetzt das
land dann hat man sich übrigens
konvergenz also vieler vielerorts hat
man sich geeinigt darauf der älteste
sohn das macht übrigens wenn man darüber
nachdenkt macht das sinn
der älteste sohn bekommt das ganze macht
das sinn weil zum beispiel wenn der
vater ein bisschen jünger stirbt ist der
älteste sohn schon mehr oder weniger
erwachsene aber die anderen sind noch
viel zu klein ist die können ja nichts
uns und er es auch stärker und zum
eltern und man muss eine regel machen
und die übrigens dann sanktioniert wird
weil das gottes willen ist aber jetzt
kommt diese interessante funktion denn
die jäger sammler natur die sagt aber
das ist doch nicht fair
wieso soll der ackerbau alles bekommen
und der der junge der da die die ziege
hütet so in der peripherie wo man keine
gute landwirtschaft betreiben kann
sondern ich dass ich das wirklich die
jäger sammler natur die hier auf schreit
und sagt das ist nicht gerecht oder ist
es die natur von uns modernen menschen
die eine lange geschichte und einen
leicht anderen gerechtigkeitssinn
entwickelt haben könnte man so denken
aber das komische ist wo kommt denn das
her
diese lange geschichte denn wir können
jetzt auf erden können wir allerhand
soziale systeme beschreiben die
forschung einerseits archäologisch
andererseits ethnologisch an jetzt noch
so lebenden nomadischen jägern und
sammlern
das sind nur ganz wenige aber die werden
sehr intensiv quantitativ erforscht da
gibt's auch eine schöne ethnologie
ethnographie von von 150 jahren her oder
mehr bis vor kurzem von all diesen
leuten da kann man ein gesamtbild heraus
machen und das stimmt genau überein mit
der archäologie nämlich diese leute sind
sehr egalitär wir haben ein großes
gerechtigkeitsempfinden die sind super
demokratisch alles wird gemeinsam
entschieden
wenn jemand meint er sei wichtiger dann
wird auch ein bisschen belächelt und
wenn es schlimmer wird dann werden
maßnahmen genommen
das militär ist auf englisch und und und
alles muss geteilt werden und das macht
auch absoluten sinn
das ist ja auch mit ein grund zu nehmen
anzunehmen dass diese rekonstruktion
zurück in die zeit passt denn für alle
arten wenn man einen bestimmten
lebensstil eine ökologie hat braucht es
dazu eine psychologie eine eine
verhaltens präferenzen muster das dazu
passt und diese für hans präferenzen zb
wenn ich jetzt jäger und sammler bin
komme ich häufig vergebens nach hause
ich habe nichts gefunden
ich habe ich habe keinen bock geschossen
kleiner ertrag einer dran aber jemand
anderes kommt und hat es also was haben
sie aus regel man muss teilen sobald man
mit sachen zurückkommt ins camp wird das
geteilt die haben manchmal ein bisschen
unterschiedlich aber die haben allerhand
regeln die man dann folgen muss damit
alle etwas bekommen und die dialoge
brauchen die müssen auch einen guten ruf
haben damit sie etwas bekommen denn wenn
wenn sie nie mit anderen teilen wollen
kriegen sie auch nichts also werden sie
dann sagen teilen ist ein teil des
menschseins ist etwas was den menschen
ausmacht absolut absolut ich kann nicht
ausschließen dass allmählich nach 10.000
jahre in bestimmten regionen vielleicht
genetische änderungen auftreten denn
aber wenn man zwei millionen jahren so
gelebt hat allmählich ist diese
lebensstil so hat sich so entwickelt
dann gibt's da genetische veranlagungen
die dieses egalitäre teilens system
aufrechterhalten
plötzlich wird alles anders mit der
landwirtschaft denn jetzt kann man
eigentum an sammeln und natürlich sind
die leute klug und die das können die
fangen damit an
kommen wir vielleicht zurück auf keiner
arbeitet und dann denn alles schlagartig
anders aber die veranlagung womit man
geboren wird ist immer noch da wie sehen
es auch bei kindern die haben diese
veranlagung welche anderen faktoren
macht denn das menschsein aussprechen
von drei naturen irgendwelcher drei
naturen charakterisieren den menschen
also die erste habe ich gerade darüber
gesprochen ich das ist diese veranlagung
was was uns eigentlich man könnte sagen
was natürlich kommt die zweite natur die
bei menschen noch wichtiger ist als bei
menschenaffen und noch viel wichtiger
als bei den anderen affenarten oder am
rand ihren ist die kultureller natur ist
die regeln die wir mal erfunden haben
die auch dazu passen und womit wir uns
die zweite natur sagt man so schön
ganz bequem sind und die passen und dann
unterscheiden wir auch noch eine dritte
natur das sind die vernunft lösungen
sagen wir wo ja die sind mal gemacht
worden steuern bezahlen nicht durch die
rote ampel fahren usw
die macht man zwar aber man die sind
nicht so zwingend im sinne dass man das
gerne machen möchte aber es scheint mir
doch es gibt gewisse aspekte in mensch
sein die sich vielleicht nicht eindeutig
der einen oder anderen natur zu ordnen
lassen
über die dann texte in der bühne zum
beispiel auch moralische anleitungen
gibt nehmen wir das thema der
homosexualität
das ist ein großes thema das eigentlich
immer im kontext von natur und wieder
natürlichkeit diskutiert wird wie steht
ihr ansatz da einerseits als forscher
des biblischen texten und andererseits
auch ihr wissen über über die menschen
auf ok erstmal was ist homosexualität
das ist eine orientierung auf das eigene
geschlecht nicht unbedingt geschlechts
handlungen mit dem eigenen geschlecht
nennen wir wenn wir homosexuelles
verhalten betrachten sehen wir es
eigentlich überall tierreich aber diese
diese selektive orientierung auf das
eigene geschlecht sehen wir eigentlich
nur beim menschen
das ist das erste
geografisch kein problem wir sehen es
aber auch bei menschen und und diese
verteilung es auch menschen die man
normalerweise aus heterosexuell
beschreiben würden da sieht man
homosexuelle handlungen häufig okay also
das ist teil der menschlichen natur dass
wir homosexualität oder zumindest
homosexuelle handlungen im gepäck haben
sie wirklich dass für beide geschlechter
komischerweise sind ist die männliche
seite viel besser erforscht ich habe
mich immer gewundert wieso das ist mein
auto schon ich vermute schon ja ich kann
es jetzt nicht unbedingt zeigen aber ich
bin da sehr sehr überrascht wenn das
nicht der fall wäre
jetzt kommen wir zur landwirtschaft was
passiert neue krankheiten entstehen
nicht unbedingt überall und direkt aber
manchmal taucht etwas neues ausdenken
sie mal jetzt an aids zum beispiel hat
angst etwas auf und das hat häufig etwas
mit übertragung von tieren zu tun und
das könnte sogar mit bestialität
zusammenhängen die übrigens im buch ganz
nah beieinander sind dann haben die
menschen immer noch ihre homosexualität
aber jetzt mit diesen ganz neuen
krankheiten sieht man sehr schnell wenn
man weiß wer was macht ungefähr und in
diesem kleinen gesellschaften wussten
die leute dass das homosexuelle häufig
eine höhere ein höheres risiko zu
übertragen haben daran stört ich
versuche das jetzt übersetzen heißt das
dass wenn biblische texte oder auch
andere religiöse schriften oder
auffassungen bestehen homosexualität zu
unterbinden einen eine menschliche
funktion also zu erhalten dass menschen
hört doch zusammen zugrundelegung
absolut denn wir stellen uns vor dass
die logik so ging tagebuch wieder
wir werden aber davon gemacht unsere
gesellschaft ist dann steht am abgrund
denn wir haben diese furchtbare solche
die uns alle heimsucht aber jemand dann
hat dann gemerkt
aber die homosexuellen die gehen zuerst
denkt sie mal wie man auf aids reagiert
hat auch als eine strafe von dann kommt
wenn man die monotheistische perspektive
hat wenn etwas schief geht ist es eine
bestrafen
ergo gott der 1
der einzige gott der alles bestimmt hast
dieses verhalten sonst würde er es nicht
bestrafen
ergo wir dürfen nicht homosexualität
betreiben und dann ist ein tolles
beispiel denn von der menschlichen natur
denn die erste natur gesehen ist es
etwas das gang und gäbe war in unserer
geschichte und es nicht nur bei uns bei
vielen arten nichts nichts spezielles
aber jetzt unter diesen neuen umständen
war es eine gefahr für die gesellschaft
und übrigens das ist auch wieso ist
steht die gesellschaft im zentrum und
nicht das individuum weil gott immer
kollektiv bestraft eine krankheit eine
dürre einer überschwemmung das ist
kollektiv also hat man die logik
verfolgt und sehr sehr sehr
beeindruckend finde ich ok das müssen
wir also unterbinden damit die
gesellschaft weiter leben kann und ich
kann ihnen sagen ach bitte lassen sie
das mal sein das ist besser
dann sagen sie es doch meine sache aber
wenn ich jetzt sage
gott hat das jetzt gesagt und wenn nicht
dann gehen wir alle dann kriegt das ein
viel größeres gewicht und dann wird es
ein 1 kommentar ein gebot
und so hat es also man kann es positiv
werten in dieser zeit war das
wahrscheinlich eine gute maßnahme
funktioniert denn der heutige mensch
noch so ist er noch versteht er sich
noch als teil eines kollektivs oder ist
die individualistische seiten schon
derart weit fortgeschritten dass auch
heute andere interpretationen möglich
und nötig sind und ich würde sagen ja
und ja und nein und nein also natürlich
dass dieses element gibt es tatsächlich
diese entwicklung gebe dass wir haben
immer noch
ich meine in so einer gesellschaft hat
man ja immer diese zwei stimmen oder
dass das leute sagen das ist falsch
sollten wir nicht sein wir müssen aufs
kollektiv beachten ist dass ganze links
rechts spektrum in der politik geht in
diese richtung
und das wie gesagt ich kann es nicht
ausschließen dass dann sogar mit
persönlichkeiten und kann genetische
veranlagung änderungen allmählich
entstanden sind ganz abwesend war es ja
nie denn sobald die jäger sammler sich
angefangen haben sich anzusiedeln sieht
man diese unterschiede entstehen sieht
man schon da wird einer der wird der
chef und und dann fängt das papier fast
schon ein kleines bisschen an
also wir haben alles ein bisschen
schlimmer dass schon bei uns drin und
jetzt kann es sie voll äußern
aber das andere gibt ja auch noch also
die das gute und das böse könnte man
sagen die ringen sich gegenseitig und
wird uns als menschen vermutlich immer
beschäftigen nicht interessiert jetzt
noch wenn sie als naturwissenschaft was
ich mit so einem buch seinem stoff
beschäftigen was was sind da für ihre
aktionen gekommen einerseits von
theologischer oder
religionswissenschaftliche seit aber vor
allem auch aus ihrer eigenen gilde von
naturwissenschaftlern die das war
interessant wir haben vor der englischen
ausgabe haben habe ich vielen kollegen
geschickt die ich noch kannte aus
amerika und wir haben es auch vielen
theologen geschickt mit der frage ob sie
etwas schreiben wollten so ein kurzes
ding so zur empfehlung von vielleicht
weil ich sie kenne die meisten
naturwissenschaftler
sozialwissenschaftler die ich
angeschrieben haben waren alle
begeistert haben schnell was geschrieben
die theologen habe ich nie was gehört
erklären sich das könnte sein dass wenn
man eine nicht kennt und so ein dickes
buch auf dem pult bekommt dass man dann
in einer woche lesen sollte dass man
sagt ja das muss ich dann erstmal
verdauen bevor ich mir da ein urteil
an mars aber es kann auch sein also ich
das ist mein favorit die hypothese sage
es mal so im allgemeinen würde es von
die meisten feedback die wir bekommen
haben sind von leute so in meinem alter
dieser ja ich bin damit aufgewachsen ein
bisschen aber ich bin einfach so weg
gedriftet
aber irgendwie wollte ich noch immer ein
bisschen wissen ja worum geht es jetzt
eigentlich und wo kommt das alles her
und die waren echt begeistert in holland
ist jetzt siebter auflage zum beispiel
also irgendwie haben wir einen nerv
getroffen nur dass leute mein eindruck
ist dass in den letzten jahren es wieder
vermehrt zu einem zu einer gewissen
zusammenführung kommt von
naturwissenschaftlich und die
geisteswissenschaftliche auch gerade
theologischen betrachten dass das wieder
ein größeres schnittfeld ist teilen sie
diesen eindruck das ist es ist ich weiß
nicht sicher ob es eindruck oder
hoffnung ist denn ich begrüße das zu zu
sehr sehr sehr denn schauen sie sich mal
meine forschung an ich möchte
menschwerdung verstehen aber dann sagen
die leute die kultur wissenschaft
betreiben hier ist der schnitt du darfst
nicht über darüber hinaus und wir
interessieren uns nicht dafür basta
vorkam
das kann doch nicht sein dass das kann
doch nicht produktiv sein wir möchten
doch gerne eines tages das alles
integrieren können und synthetisieren
können und das geht nur wenn man
respektvoll dialog betreibt und nicht
sagt ja du bist kein experte hier nein
natürlich nicht niemand kann überall
experte sein
also wenn man versucht diese perspektive
mal ineinander zu schieben
dann denke ich dass wir alle sehr viel
besser verstehen werden was uns zu
menschen gemacht hat und immer noch
macht und vielleicht uns auch helfen
dann mit neuen herausforderungen klar zu
kommen das ist natürlich das bleibt ein
problem
es bleibt ein problem und wir werden
sicher weiterhin mit diesen fragen uns
auch beschäftigen wer weiß vielleicht
wird irgendein x sie oder jemand anders
dann in der folge auch nach der bibel
den koran entsprechend untersuchen
ich bedanke mich auf jeden fall ganz
herzlich für dieses gespräch
vielen dank wenn sie wissen wollen was
ein theologe und bibelforscher von den
diskutierten thesen hält dann besuchen
sie die srf kultur website wir wollten
es nämlich auch wissen und haben
nachgefragt hier in der sternstunde
religion nimmt sie jetzt ein film mit
ins begegnungszentrum felsentor auf der
regel dort wird seit einiger zeit eine
sehr spezielle form der achtsamkeit
erprobt die meditation mit tieren wie
das gehen soll
schauen sie selbst einen schönen sonntag
und bis bald
[Musik]